the M2 Max MacBook Pros are official now
because we have leaked Benchmark
performance results now I'm going to be
sharing those with you along with some
very weird things how it performs to the
M2 Chip what kind of uh nanometer
process this seems like it's on and why
this is extremely weird now we've been
talking about the M2 chips for a long
time the pros the max we've been
anticipating these machines talking
about three nanometer versions coming
out and the performance it will get from
that and even though a lot of us thought
we're gonna have a November event that
obviously didn't happen Apple pushed it
back so was it worth the wait well
shrimp Apple Pro was actually the one
that pointed out these benchmarks first
he's a leaker that is very very accurate
and here we're showing 12 cores 96
gigabytes of RAM so that's a nice
upgrade from the 64 gigabyte for those
that need it we also have a little bit
more info about the core configuration
now we've known as we're going to have a
12 core for a while so we're still up in
arms about is it going to be eight
performance cores and four efficiency
plus upgraded Graphics or on the M2 Max
will be 10 performance cores two
efficiency and then extra graphics and
I'll let you guys know what I think it's
looking like based on the performance
numbers we have so let's dive right into
it here are the numbers so we have 1853
and 13 855 for multi-core now this was
the first leak and as you see I am very
disappointed because these numbers do
not look good at all in any way that you
look at it now if we go ahead and
compare it to the M1 Max that got 12
333 for multi-core that is only a 12
difference in performance and that is a
shame if it's going to be a year and a
half later Intel has done even better
than this now looking at the single core
we have 1853 compared to a thousand
seven hundred and fifty five that is
only a five percent Improvement in
performance that doesn't make any sense
at all now for those of you guys who
think that might this might be a fake
leak well if we take a look lower here
it literally says we are running Mac OS
13.2 this was set to be a beta that's
actually unreleased even to developers
this means that if somebody at Apple
most likely or maybe somebody that gave
the laptop to to test because this
software isn't anywhere and that also
makes this leak a lot more likely that
it's legit now we also see that it's
labeled the Apple M2 Max it shows 12
processing cores there's no processor
right now that's 12 cores from Apple
silicon we have 3.54 gigahertz for the
frequency so faster than M1 Max and 96
gigs of RAM now I went through all of
these single scores here and I compared
them to the M1 Max and I noticed that
the crypto score was actually a lot
lower on this new M2 Max than the M1 Max
now there were a few different results
that had some nice improvements like
camera for example PDF rendering we also
had speech recognition but for the most
part everything lined up almost
identically which doesn't make sense and
if we compare it to the M2 MacBook Pro
the single core score is a lot higher
and the multi-score score is also fairly
high on that chip now that is also a
five nanometer chip not three nanometers
so why is a five nanometer chip that has
been out here for half a year now or
more going to be beating out in single
core the M2 Max once that comes out
which would be likely a year after the
M2 air and M2 Pro I also looked through
some of these single performance results
and a lot of those actually matched up
to the M2 Max which is showing that the
performance of that is likely on par
with five nanometer M2 not three
nanometer M3 but it actually gets worse
we did a little bit of math on the M2
Chip in the performance of its
performance course versus efficiency and
when we grab the single core score and
we multiply it we get
7764 for the performance and that leaves
us with 12 903 for the efficiency cores
which are four of those 323 Port
efficiency core now the best leak
performance score I found for the M2 Max
at 1889 for single and 14 586 for
multi-core score that gives us 18 better
performance than the M1 Max for
multi-core and then seven percent for
single core still not great nowhere SD
are some of the gains that even Intel
AMD have been getting with their latest
upgraded processors now doing the same
math if we are going to have eight
performance cores and four efficiency
for 12 cores we'll get 15 a hundred and
twelve multi-core score if it gets scale
and it doesn't have extra heat issues uh
which the cores are similar there and
then we have to add in the performance
of the efficiency cores because with the
M2 they are pretty powerful and that
gives a total of 16
405 and that is almost 2 000 points
higher than the best score that we see
now that is about 30 percent faster than
the M1 Max and that is going off of the
lower performance count and going off of
the M2 Chip that is five nanometer an
old old design and still that would
actually be a reasonable result not what
we're seeing in these leaks now we also
talks of the M2 Max having 10
performance cores and two efficiency to
better differentiate it from the M1 Pro
because with that like the M1 Max and
pro we told people just get the M1 Pro
if you use CPU best tasks performance is
the same so that would help people want
to upgrade and if we had that if we do
the math that would give us 18 890 for
the performance course 10 of those plus
the efficiency 19
500. now that is based off a five
nanometer if they could keep it cool of
course which I don't know if they can
probably they cannot with this
configuration and that would be a game
changer of the laptop that is what we
want that's what we've been waiting for
but of course if it's on three nanometer
they could achieve this performance and
better in single core but at the same
time it would run cooler and take less
power and would be able to achieve
something like a 19500 and we thought we
were getting three nanometer because
this machine got pushed back
but it looks like off of these scores it
is five nanometer and actually even
worse than the M2 by not scaling as well
and that is a huge bummer if this is
true now there's still a chance that
they could have multiple versions they
have a five millimeter version three
nanometer version they're trying to
choose this could be one of the older
machines and they might have pushed it
back for three nanometer these ships
should be ready in time so we're hoping
for that but of course with the economy
and everything that's happening Apple
could want to wait to release a three
nanometer it's going to cost a lot more
when more people are going to be willing
to buy hopefully later down the line but
that would just really suck that would
mean we're waiting another three four
months and then another year and a half
for a much better three nanometer M3 Max
at that point which is what we all want
in the machine that would be super quiet
cool and extremely fast you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below click that Circle
subscribe check out one of those videos
right there and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]